today on the matt walsh show after two
months of being kept from the public the
body cam footage showing the minutes
leading up to george floyd's death has
been released
let's just say that the that the issue
is far more complicated
than what the media led us to believe
we'll discuss that in detail today also
five headlines including a white espn
host
openly gloating over the injury of a
black nba player who stood for the
national anthem
and in our daily cancellation i'm going
to try to soothe the fears of a paranoid
journalist who thinks that pickup trucks
were invented to kill pedestrians i will
try to make him feel better about that
and then i will cancel him
all of that on the way but first let's
talk about paint your life uh those
sponsors of ours who are a really big
fan of personally i think one of the
most meaningful gifts you can give a
person is artwork and i don't know about
you but i'm not exactly a gifted artist
myself so i need someone else to
actually
make the art uh fortunately paint your
life has on staff many extremely skilled
artists who can turn a photograph
into a priceless work of art i mean this
is what they've been they do they've
been doing it for a long time you won't
be disappointed if you want to get
a truly meaningful gift you've got to
try paintyourlife.com
uh you get a professional hand-painted
portrait this isn't some photoshop deal
all right they're painting it by hand
created from any photo
at a truly affordable price choose from
a team of world-class artists
work with them until every detail is
perfect and
uh the user-friendly platform lets you
order a custom made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes it's
super easy i'm telling you i've done it
myself
and i was expecting it to be way more
complicated and sort of painful for me
than it than it actually was it wasn't
painful at all and it also
was way less expensive than than i
thought it was gonna be so i was
pleasantly surprised
every step of the way all you have to do
is send any picture it could be yourself
your children family special place
special pet whatever
and they will turn it into art it's as
simple as that they they're doing all
the work
making it easier for you at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed and right now
as a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that's right 20
off and free shipping to get this
special offer text the word matt
to 64 000 that's matt m-a-t-t 264
000 text matt 264 000 paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
all right we're going to um talk about
this now
we'll we'll we'll back up and review a
few things um
two months after footage of george
floyd's death went viral sparking an
epidemic of rioting and violence that
killed dozens of people and caused
untold damage to countless communities
across the country
body cam footage of the incident has
finally been made public
was published by the daily mail it was
leaked
to the outlet and then they published it
uh the additional video
it lends crucial context to the fatal
encounter between
floyd and officer derek shovin it also
gives insight
importantly into the states of mind of
both men that's one of the main things
you take away from this
now given that this tragic episode and
the reaction to it has been the most
significant story in the country for two
months and one of the most significant
of the past decade
you might think if you didn't know any
better that the media would treat the
new evidence
this new footage as a rather big story
you might think it'd be headlines
everywhere it'd be the main thing
they're talking about but so far
the opposite has been the case the news
media for the most part has had a
noticeably muted reaction to the footage
one might even say
suspiciously muted perhaps
that's because the story the new footage
tells is
at the very least far more complicated
than the one the media and activists
have been screaming into our ears
since may um that story with which we
are all extremely familiar of course is
that george floyd was a compliant
peaceful man who was strangled to death
they said by a racist
anti-black sociopathic cop
straightforward we were told quite
literally black and white
and and the only opinion one can really
have about it is the kind of opinion
that is easily
expressed on a protest sign that's what
we were told
now of course we've known from the
beginning that some of this was to put
it gently
not exactly accurate
you know however floyd was or wasn't
acting on the day of his death
it strains credulity to use a word like
peaceful to describe a man who once
forced his way into a woman's home and
robbed her at gunpoint in front of her
child
that's a very difficult thing to call
peaceful
as for the racism claim well there's
there's was perhaps no evidence to
disprove it but neither was ever
any evidence presented to support it
it's merely assumed
that any white police officer who kills
a black suspect
no matter the circumstances is motivated
at some level by racism
now some of that some some of these
killings may be motivated by racism i
don't know but the burden of proof
is on those who make the claim yet those
who make the claim rarely acknowledge
that there is any burden of proof to
meet much less make any honest attempt
to meet it
also anyone following the story has
known for some time that
in addition to everything else according
to the medical examiner's report
floyd was not strangled to death and did
not die from asphyxiation as the media
had so confidently declared in the
immediate aftermath
it was found that floyd who had
pre-existing heart conditions
three illicit drugs in his system
including fentanyl which is 50 times
more potent morphine
and known to cause respiratory distress
it was found that he died of
cardiopulmonary arrest complicating law
enforcement subdual restrain
and neck compression that's what the
medical examiner said
a medical examination performed by an
examiner hired by floyd's family
contradicted those findings claiming
that he was in fact
he did in fact die of asphyxiation so
that was the status of things um
prior to this week's developments we had
an out of context video
a bunch of assumptions and not much more
and those assumptions were considered
reason enough to burn our cities
now the new footage doesn't necessarily
clarify
everything in fact it does the opposite
it adds complications and nuances to an
issue
that was once assumed to be utterly and
completely straightforward
it's not the body cameras worn by
officers alex kang
and thomas lane the first two cops on
the scene show
a number of things they show that floyd
is agitated and uncooperative from the
first moment that officers arrive in
response to a call from a business owner
who accused floyd of trying to pass off
counterfeit bills
floyd is in his car when law enforcement
first shows up
one of the officers draws his weapon
because floyd is initially hesitant to
show his hands
they keep telling him show his hands he
doesn't gun comes out once floyd
places his hands on his head in full
view of the officers
the gun is holstered after much coaxing
he's eventually removed from his car
taken to the police cruiser now floyd
appears to have
trouble walking on his way over to the
police car and they ask him
several times if he's on something and
he was he was on several things
he shouts ow and you know seems to be in
pain even though he's only being grabbed
by his arm
he's you know he's quite uh he's
doing a lot of screaming and acting as
always in pain once at the vehicle
he repeatedly refuses to get inside
saying that he's claustrophobic though
he'd just been sitting in his own car
without any apparent difficulty on the
contrary he was extremely
reluctant to get out of his own vehicle
only to then claim he's too
claustrophobic to get back inside one at
one point as officers try to convince
him to get in the car floyd actually
says
that he'd rather lay on the ground he
also says several times that he's going
to die
that he can't breathe all of this before
he was on the ground
and he ends up there on the ground
because he either falls or pushes
himself out
of the other side of the police cruiser
as officers struggle to get inside
get him inside the vehicle from that
point the scene unfolds as we all saw on
the initial video
uh two months ago now you can go online
and watch the full body cam footage
i would recommend doing that so you get
the whole context obviously i can't play
all of that footage here
but i will play a clip of the
interaction between floyd and the
officers
at the police cruiser because i think
this is perhaps the most
relevant portion hands on top of your
head
step out of the vehicle and step away
from me all right step out and face away
step out and face away from the please
don't shoot me please man
i'm not gonna shoot you step on
stop resisting that
right now and i just had kobe's man i
don't want to go back to that okay
i'll roll the windows down hey listen
dang man listen
i'm not that kind of guy i'm not a bad
guy man in the car
i'm not a bad guy
ah
okay
now as previously stated none of this
conclusively exonerates the officers
of any and all wrongdoing but it does
establish a few facts that might
mitigate their culpability number one to
review the facts
george floyd was uncooperative clearly
intoxicated and resisting arrest
number two the officers were remarkably
calm and reasonable
for most of the interaction number three
george floyd claimed that he couldn't
breathe and was going to die well before
he had a knee on his neck
number four the officers never did or
said
a single thing that any reasonable
person
could possibly construe as racist
now all those points are important but
let's let's focus on point three for a
moment here
floyd said that he was too
claustrophobic to get in the police car
and that he might die
and couldn't breathe even though he was
just in sitting in a car
he was screaming that he was in pain
even though officers at that point
weren't doing anything that could have
caused him any physical harm we should
also note that
he said at one point that his mom had
just died even though she'd been dead
for over two years
now the officers would not have known
that you know when his mom died
obviously but
presumably but the point is that cops
they hear nonsense like this from
suspects all day every day just ask them
and they'll tell you
this can create a kind of boy who cried
wolf situation where it's harder to tell
when a suspect is actually in distress
if he's claiming he's in distress the
entire time even when he's not
then how do you know when he really is
when floyd was on the ground saying he
was going to die
it was no different from what he was
saying while he was standing or what he
was saying when he was in the car
these facts may not be exculpatory but
they they certainly are
relevant the narrative as it was
originally presented
does not take into account any of these
details it demands that
demands that we see the event as nothing
more or less than a want an act of
random cruelty
with nothing precipitating it no context
and with not even an
ounce of blame or responsibility to be
shared by floyd himself
now in reality floyd may still be the
victim of some degree of negligence but
it seems that that the murder charge
will be difficult to prove the truth
just
isn't that simple and it rarely is and
that's a lesson we would all do well
to remember for the future especially
where these police
videos are concerned one final point i
want to make here because i can't move
on without uh pointing this out
as i said the media has not been anxious
to talk about
the body cam footage they have not been
anxious
but the interesting thing is that cnn
did report rather extensively
on this body cam footage back before
anyone in the public had seen it
they were able to view it weeks ago it
was being held from release at that
point by the courts but they let
the media watch it and that enabled cnn
to describe it in their own words
without anyone contradicting them
and you can imagine how that went
the video offers basically context
includes that aren't included in the
transcript
mainly the emotion of it and the speed
with which
this happens remember these officers
responded to a call over a fake bill
being used
within 36 seconds of them speaking to
the store owner
that last words with the store owner
they now had a gun pointed in
george floyd's face saying let me see
your effing hands
after initially knocking on the window
with a flashlight
and then throughout that interaction
george floyd is sobbing throughout as he
is pleading with officers asking
what he did eventually calming down to
the point where he seems to be complying
and the struggle ensues
then it's minutes after that another
struggle trying to get him
into a police car and this is part of
why
viewing the video as opposed to just a
transcript is so important
the last words listed in at least a
transcript for former officer
thomas lane lists those words as please
but then as you watch the actual video
you actually see
a little bit later there's another
please and then man
i can't breathe this is actually a very
important lesson
in media bias what you just saw there
and it's
it's it's the true reality of fake news
that we should all understand
you heard the cnn reporter describing
the body cam footage weeks before
anyone in the public had seen it was his
description a lie
no not really um the effect
is yeah it was misleading and
intentionally so but nothing he said was
in itself factually inaccurate floyd
does cry and plead
and there are points in the video when
he seems to be complying of course he's
not really complying at any point at all
but
uh he's resisting the whole time but he
does seem to be complying
in individual spots in the video that's
how it was phrased
and when you describe it like that like
the reporter does here it sounds pretty
damning for the police
when you watch it on the other hand it
feels very different
and looks very different that's because
cnn left out many details
and this is where the fake news almost
always comes in it's what they leave
out it's not what they say it's what
they leave out they leave out that he's
clearly intoxicated they leave out that
he he says he's gonna die and that he
can't breathe
before he was on the ground they leave
out that the officers themselves were
patient and reasonable
they leave out that floyd had a
mysterious bout of claustrophobia right
when they tried to get him in the car
they leave out that he said that he
wanted to lay on the ground they leave
out nearly
every detail that i already mentioned
and i'm not going to continue to rehash
here
they leave all of that out so they
issued a report that was dishonest
misleading
grotesque reckless defamatory and yet
technically accurate and that's that is
fake news that's how it works it's far
more insidious than we than we tend to
think and the way that we portray it we
you know we act like they're out there
fabricating outlandish stories all the
time and there has been a little bit of
that but mostly not what they do is they
take
real stories and they whittle them down
into the shape and form getting rid of
the details they don't like
whittling them down into the shape and
form uh that that they prefer that's
exactly what happened here
perfect example of it but there's the
full context uh
that we all should know and
now we do let's move on to five
headlines
[Music]
okay before we get into our five
headlines here um i want to tell you
about our very good friends at rock auto
you know it's so much easier to get your
auto parts online than it is to go to
the store
uh these days and not just these days
but any day really i just did this a few
days ago
needed a part for my suburban and went
on rock auto got
took care of it in three minutes you
know three minutes as compared to how
long it would take to go to the store
you go there and
oftentimes they don't have what you're
looking for anyway they're gonna have to
order it online why not cut out the
middleman just go
take your phone out of your pocket go on
your computer uh whatever you want to do
and go to rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
uh why spin up to twice as much for the
same parts that's a simple question okay
there's there's no reason to do it
rockauto.com is a family business
they've been serving online
uh auto parts customers online for 20
years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and they're the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers so
they're not going to try to milk you
for for every dime that they can they're
going to offer you the best price
that they possibly can amazing selection
reliably low prices
all the parts your car truck will ever
need rockauto.com go to rockauto.com
right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck right walsh
in there uh how did you hear about this
box so that they know that
we sent you okay some
really shocking footage uh incredible
horrible footage out of beirut and
there's video of this from different
angles all over social media right now
massive explosion i want you to watch
this with the sound watch this
yeah from what i'm being told uh we're
not not what i'm being told like i have
special sources from what i've read
uh they're they're right now trying to
blame that on a fireworks
factory explosion or something i
i've never seen a fireworks factory
explode i'm confess
i'm a little skeptical that it would
look like that uh but also
i'm not gonna really speculate because i
have no idea whatsoever
um but there is there is a story that
everyone will be of course following
let's go number two donald trump for
some reason did an interview with axios
axios axis maybe the o is silent i don't
know ax ios
something i don't know how to pronounce
but so he was on hbo giving an interview
and some clips of that interview have
been circling circulating and
the clips are well they're not they're
not great they're
really not great at all let's let's just
watch one of the clips
john lewis is lying in state in the u.s
capitol how do you think history will
remember
john lewis i don't know i really don't
know uh i don't know
uh i don't know john lewis uh he chose
not to come to my uh
uh inauguration uh he chose uh i don't
i never met john lewis actually i don't
believe do you find him impressive
uh i can't say one way or the other i
find a lot of people impressive i find
many people not impressive but
no but i didn't find his story he didn't
come to my
inauguration he didn't come to my state
of the union speeches
and that's okay that's his right and
again
nobody has done more right more
americans than i have i understand he
should have come back but i think he
made a big mistake
but taking your relationship with him
out of it do you find his story
impressive what he's done
for this country he was a person that
devoted a lot of energy and a lot of
heart
to civil rights but there were many
others also
there's a petition to rename the edmund
pettus bridge in selma alabama as the
john
lewis bridge would you support that idea
i would i would have no objection to it
if they'd like to do it yeah it's great
would have no objection to it whatsoever
and that actually is not at all the
worst bit of the interview but it is the
shortest clip i could find so that's why
i decided to play it that's how i make
editorial decisions
it's all about efficiency so listen
here's all i'm i'm gonna say okay
just some unsolicited advice that won't
be heated and won't matter so i'm just
offering it up to the universe
okay i'm shouting it out into the ether
for no reason
um trump
should take one of two paths here either
stop doing media stop doing interviews
the biden approach or do them
but come in prepared with a plan and be
on the ball
ready to answer basic questions
i think either of those approaches will
be fine i really i have no preference
either one i take either one but doing
the interviews and having no plan
and just stammering around the questions
evading them in the clunkiest possible
way constantly bringing everything back
to your own personal gripes
that is the worst of all worlds that is
literally the worst
possible way to approach this particular
facet of campaigning
and i find it find it uh endlessly
frustrating and
anyone like me who really doesn't want
democrats to win in 2020
should also be frustrated by this and
should be voicing their frustrations
because it is it is i think par in part
because of all the yes men around donald
trump
and of all of his fans who just will
never criticize him um
it's in part because of them that he
thinks that he can just
wander waltz his way into an interview
um
with a with a talented interviewer which
this guy was
and sit down with no preparation and
just wing it and say yeah bring it you
know
and he's going to come off well that's
what he thinks about himself
it's not true he most people don't have
the talent to do that
maybe some people do trump is not one of
those some people
he's not he needs to be prepared or he's
going to get
chewed up and spit out which is what
happened here
and and also by the way you know i've
i've read some i've seen some reactions
on social media from trump
people you know trying to pretend this
was like an unfair
interview and these were gotcha
questions no they weren't i mean i
i'm i'm quite certain that this reporter
hates donald trump's guts
so what the questions he asked were
actually perfectly fair
and reasonable um they weren't gotcha
questions
if a question like you know what do you
think of john lewis
if that's a gotcha question for you
then again you're too incompetent to be
doing interviews at all
that's a really easy question question
to answer oh he's a civil rights icon
a real hero sorry to see you sorry i was
very sad at his passing
that's it that's all you have to say and
then when they come back with oh but you
guys were at odds he didn't come to your
he didn't come to your uh inauguration i
mean it seems like
oh that's fine that's that's fine he has
every right to do that but that doesn't
change the fact that he was a heroic man
and uh
have great respect for him and his
family there you go that's all you have
to say
and the thing is before you try to say
well trump didn't want to pander he's
not he's going to
shoot from the hip and he's not
pandering not true he got around to
saying that
right but it's just before he got there
he stammered around for a minute and a
half and kept saying over and over again
like like a sixth grader with his
feelings hurt he didn't come to my
inauguration
just cut that crap out and get right to
the answer
or don't do the interviews be like biden
hide in the basement
all right let's go to number three uh
jonathan isaac of the orlando magic
was the first player to stand for the
anthem before a game um
and and you know this is literally
taking a heroic stand here
you have to think about what that
involves me he's the first guy
in the entire nba to include
cochise and everybody actually standing
to show his respect for the flag
and then um isaac shortly after blew out
his acl and is of course
done for the for the year the left
wonderful people that they are have been
gloating about this including an espn
host dan levitar who posted a poll
online uh asking whether the injury was
funny and now lebotard has
apologized and claimed that he wasn't
claiming it was funny he was just
asking whether other people think it was
funny short so
laboratory to be clear is white and
isaac is black
so this is a white man laughing over a
black man's injury because the black man
doesn't agree with his politics
that's what's happening there but the
thing i really wanted to to
hone in on here is is the line of
questioning that isaac endured
after the first game where he stood for
the anthem and didn't wear the black
lives matter t-shirt
listen to this this is this is this is a
question he was asked
at a post game press conference so you
didn't kneel during the anthem but you
also didn't wear a black lives matter
shirt
uh do you believe that black lives
matter
absolutely i believe that black lives
matter um
a lot went into my decision and part of
it is first off
um is my thought that you know kneeling
or wearing a black lives matter t-shirt
um don't go hand in hand with supporting
black lives
and so um i felt like just me personally
um and what it is that i believe in
standing on the stands that um
i do believe that black lives matter but
i i just felt like it was the decision
that i had to make and and
i didn't um i don't feel like
putting putting that shirt on and
kneeling one hand in hand with
um supporting black lives matter that it
made me
support black lives or not i believe
that you know for myself
my my life has been supported through
the gospel
of jesus christ and that everyone is
made in the image of god and that we all
foreign's glory
do you believe that black lives matter
that was the act this is a black man
you're talking to
that would be a dumb enough question if
it was a white it would be
exceedingly dumb uh to ask a white
athlete that if he stood for the
national anthem oh does standing for the
national anthem mean that you hate black
people and think their lives don't
matter
exceedingly dumb to ask a white but
you're asking a black guy
so you're asking them so are you
standing for the national anthem because
you think your own life doesn't matter
what talk about a non-sequitur
are you really asking me that you [ __ ]
i mean this will be my response
of course this player is much nicer and
more gracious than me jonathan isaac so
he
he he he answers the question without
indicating how incredibly stupid it is
good for him there
very patient man um but just
they actually asked a black man whether
he thinks black lives matter
um all right number four
here's governor cuomo lobbing a rather
large
accusation at donald trump
this was a colossal blunder
how covert was handled by this federal
government colossal blunder
shame on all of you six
months lives lost
hit the reset button yes
but the way the medical experts are
talking about it it won't work
it won't work unless you hit the reset
button and you start with the truth
because if the american people are
continued
lying to the confusion and the chaos and
the denial will continue
hit the reset button it's called the
truth it's called the plain truth
the american people are smart
if the president actually tells them the
truth and says
i made a mistake he's not going to be
telling them anything they don't know
every american knows he made a mistake
every american knows this was the worst
government blunder in modern history
worst governmental blunder in modern
history
now you know where i'm going with this i
i don't even think i need to say it but
this is the guy who made the decision
to force nursing homes to take in covet
patients
directly resulting and along with other
democrat governors
directly resulting directly causing
um the deaths of thousands of elderly
people force them to take them in
thousands of elderly people die and he's
accusing donald trump of the worst
blunder
in modern history all of the blunders
that he's accusing donald trump of
are things that trump said and granted
some of that stuff was very stupid
like when he said that the 15 people
have coveted and it's going to go away
after this and
it's going to magically disappear he
said that a few times very stupid thing
to say
those are words though okay this is
policy
the blunder that cuomo made was a policy
that killed thousands of people so
i i think cuomo's being a little modest
here he's being he's being a little too
humble and he's
he's trying to say to trump oh no trump
can have the top spot for worse
blunder not not me i'll give it the
truth no no no no qualm i i
i find your humility admirable but i
think actually you get to take that top
spot for worse governmental blunder
in modern history number five um finally
it's maybe a stretch to put this in the
headline section but i'm not sure where
else to put it so
here we are a tweet from the wnba
account on twitter it says
have you been keeping up with the 2020
season test your knowledge every monday
to see if you're the biggest wnba fan
there's a link to the trivia i thought
it could be fun if we um
actually went ahead and uh tried to take
this quiz together i just thought you
know
to test wnba knowledge because i figure
that wnba trivia
is the hardest test you could ever take
getting all this right would be like a
be like the moment in goodwill hunting
where matt damon solves
the math equation nobody else could get
it it seems almost impossible there's
probably
two or three people on earth who could
ace
a wnba trivia quiz and um
so we're going to try and see how this
goes all right
let's say follow along last weekend i
don't know how many questions there are
hopefully it's not that many because
this bit will
really get old after about two minutes
last weekend uh kennedy carter maybe
it's kennedy
c-h-e-n-n-nnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
nedy kennedy kennedy
that better not be not be pronounced
kennedy you name your kid kennedy and
spell it with a ch i don't know i don't
know how it's pronounced i mean i'm a
big fan don't get me wrong
been following kennedy carter for for
years um made her rookie debut for oh
well she's a rookie so i didn't i guess
i've been following her for weeks
feels like it feels like i've known her
forever last weekend kennedy carter
made her rookie debut for which team
chicago sky
washington mystics atlanta dream
dallas wings connecticut son
what do all the team names sound like
crayola cover colors
chicago sky atlanta dream connecticut's
on um okay i'm gonna say
uh chicago skye
nope she was selected by the atlanta
dream all right
which team finished the first week of
the season with a three-in-one record
all of the above minnesota lynx seattle
storm washington mystics or chicago sky
first of all the all of the above option
is at the top there's nothing above it
all the above goes at the bottom it's
like the wba they can't even do a trivia
quiz right
um no offense but usually when you when
you're you know doing a quiz and there's
an all of the above i say from
experience as a student who
took many quizzes without ever really
knowing the answers to anything
because i never studied or did my
homework usually when there's an
all-of-the-above
option and there isn't one in every
question you go with all the above so
i'll say all of the above correct
okay that's one which rookie dropped 33
points in her second game
satou sabali sabrina
ionskew lauren cox bella allery
kennedy carter big fans of all these
women
uh great great players but i'm gonna say
lauren cox if if any of these players
uh you know when you follow her career
even go back to high school um
and and you follow you know considering
the the position she plays on the court
um of point guard
i i just think that lauren cox is oh no
it's not it's sabrina ions scored 33
points well good for her
okay which player is leading the league
in points per game
after week one ariel atkins
aja wilson bria hartley kelsey mitchell
dewanna bonner uh i gotta say
that i know for a fact it is ariel
atkins she is a scoring
machine she can even jump up and touch
the net
pretty impressive and nope it was dawana
bonner currently leads the league
all right so i got one out of four
that's the end of the quiz one out of
four
this this puts me easily in the top five
percent of all
wnba fans um that i could get one out of
four right so i i gotta
i gotta give myself a lot of credit for
that that was a lot of fun hopefully we
all learned something about the wnba
today you didn't think you would learn
wnba trivia but you did we're gonna go
to our daily cancellation
but first um if you're not a daily wire
member all-access member you're really
missing out all
access is our most exclusive membership
tier featuring behind the scenes
access to us the podcast hosts as well
as writers and special guests
all access members also get early access
to new daily wired products and as part
of that
i'm excited to announce our brand new
limited count collectors edition
baseball bat in collaboration with
pillbox bat company
handcrafted here in the u.s emblazoned
with a daily wired logo there's a
limited
number of these one to 100 right that
we're doing and um
the the uh individual number will be on
each of these bats okay so these bats
are currently only being offered to our
all access members
so join our up or upgrade now before
they're all gone all access members also
get to participate in our all-access
live discussions
you get a lot plus you get two leftist
tiers tumblers and you get 20 off if you
use the coupon code all access right now
go to dailywire.com walsh okay now for
our daily cancellation
uh we have up to bat here so to speak
ryan cooper he's a correspondent for the
publication of the week
and he was reacting to an article in the
wall street journal an article that
complains that pickup trucks are too big
these days
because someone decided to write an
entire article
around the kind of banal observation you
make when you've been in a car for seven
hours with somebody and there's nothing
left to talk about so you're just
driving along and you turn to them and
say
well these pickup trucks are really big
you notice that really big these days
yeah yeah they are
yeah well they're really big in fact
all kinds of cars are big these days
yeah
uh riveting conversation is always in
the cars but
ryan's observation though is not quite
that banal in fact it's actually pretty
fascinating this is what he says
sales of mega pickups which have
basically been deliberately designed to
intimidate and kill pedestrians are
booming
it's one thing to say that they're too
big it's another thing to say they're
deliberately
designed to kill pedestrians
now uh well no no sorry he didn't say
delivery he said
basically deliberately designed and can
i just say for the record
as we're doing this in fact i'm going to
cancel the word basically too because
the word basically is not as it is so
often used
in escape hatch allowing you to make
wildly inaccurate claims okay
people throw the word basically into a
sentence thinking that
they can then veer off into fantasy land
and basically
is this magical incantation that makes
their fantasy into a reality
so this happens all the time especially
in arguments i mean we've all it's very
common these days where you say
something like um
well i think that we we spend too much
on entitlements uh
entitlement programs in this country and
the person responds oh
oh so you're basically saying that we
should round up all the poor people and
throw them into the sea
isn't it that's that's basically what
you're saying
no that's not what i'm basically saying
at all in fact it's uh
what i'm basically saying is what i said
because it's a pretty basic
concept so i said what i said and that's
really all that i said
as for the claim that ryan is making
here i hope i don't have to spend too
much time
debunking it um you know uh
i i i don't know if i need to present
like sources and evidence to
to debunk the claim that pickup trucks
are designed
with the intention of killing
pedestrians um
i guess he imagines a scenario where
people go to the dealership
like the ford dealership and say yeah
i'm looking for a pickup truck with a
good towing capacity
a long bed oh and the ability to
pulverize
five old ladies at a time while they're
crossing the street you have anything
for that oh right this way sir yeah we
have
we have a section just for that right
over here um that's what he imagines
let me put his mind to rest ryan
don't worry um i myself have
have lived in many small towns and rural
type areas
i've been around quite a lot of pickup
trucks i don't drive one myself
as i said before i drive a suburban
because i have
four kids as well um
and but i've been around them quite a
bit and i i can tell you that they are
not designed to kill you so you can calm
down
city boy you uh no one's gonna run you
over while you're sitting at your cafe
eating french pancakes or whatever the
hell you're doing
pickup trucks are not designed for that
they're designed very simply to carry
machine guns
really big machine guns and that's how
pickup drivers
kill pedestrians with machine guns okay
and
it's it's it's a much quicker death
you know less less painful so
just stop being so paranoid and stop
complaining also all right
and you're canceled um
there we go hopefully hopefully i i
thought we could we could end on a
positive note there just a word
of encouragement for our friend uh ryan
all right we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there